like the the of the of the multiplayer
games that are coming out of PlayStation
right that we don't really know about I
think the only one that isn't going to
be cross gen is the bungee whatever the
Bungie's next thing is I think you're
right I I think yeah yeah yeah that
sounds about right anything else
anything else to me they're getting that
player base and then to the point of the
PC Day One release yeah where you at a
pure multiplayer experience just pure
multiplayer you need a big uh Community
around it day one I would be
[Music]
don't believe why don't believe it for
um for The Last of Us factions is
when you look at the the press release
about what they talked about the game
seems like it is a lot more narratively
focused than just a straight up
multiplayer game I think that Africa is
going to be in there